game we got a low ticket Alert in
Cleveland and Columbus so if you want to
catch the show you better make a move
baby yeah gang there's a handful of
tickets left at each show and then
obviously the second show added at the
Vogel theater in Red Bank New Jersey
August 11th that's more than halfway
sold out get those tickets let's sell it
out gang we'll see you out there peace
peace welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage show where
you find out if your favorite comedians
are classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it out they're
good to be classy yeah okay just a big
old piece of trash I'm your hostage
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in the
new edition she just went off to get a
Brazilian okay yeah getting ready for
the summer that Fogo de Chao
it's all you can eat folks don't he's
open my co-host is coming at you from
across the table it's a family episode
just to bozos and the homies and the
boys he is the CEO of Ru garbage he's
International businessman and the kid as
I said last week loves a flatbread pizza
got another one this weekend that wasn't
a flatbread it was a thin cry personal
pain Kippy giving
Jay Kevin James Ryan what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
[Music]
cooking then obviously one of the two
greatest websites of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage yeah
sign up over there it is a hoot you get
weekly episodes of ayg weekly episodes
of hard feelings you get all the bonus
content to comment for Mindy that's
going to be dropping pretty soon so a
lot going on over there can't be doing
180 in a [__] Indy car
still fuel to my plums
hey buddy there was come in that suit
before I put it on all right I took a
Percocet same thing
um and also of course the second
greatest are you garbage.com for all
your ayg needs yeah ticks are you are
you in the market for a Zippo style
lighter then head over to Ru garbage.com
because those things are flying off
their shelves that's how I know our fans
are trash those guys are eating those
things
foreign
[Laughter]
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
works the twos the threes and the fours
crosses the t's dots the eyes and he's
got a big old hog on him give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen are
going right to the chase this week baby
let him know whoa speaking of Chase I
got [__] Rocket Fuel of my blood
after after being down there that Indy
500. I'm a race guy now yeah it was a
good weekend man what's up Good Time
shout out to everybody shout out to
Louisa yes shout out to the
international Motor Speedway
Indianapolis Motor Speedway there you go
yeah [__] wild time wild time and of
course my new best friend Mr Brian Adams
playing all the hits sure playing all
the hits I mean that was the most Bozo
concert I've ever been to In My Life
talk about it on hard feelings I wasn't
crazy about the set list I already have
an email out to his people that was a
swing in a minute so I can improve the
life performance you go right in with
summer is 69 what are you doing
can I open up with something new in
front of 50 000 people I mean the booze
started in the back
boo I think it was me I saw it
[Laughter]
about what a weekend man it was a good
time yes it was great it was good stuff
we'll see you guys next week
uh I got a little something to get into
a little bit I tried to uh
uh I cut in line pretty heavy the other
day where at the supermarket you did
yeah what a piece of [__] through a
flashbang down the aisle
well so the way mine's set up there's
self checkout on the left uh-huh regular
checkout on the right it's about three
and three or just Steel on the far right
I know I mean
uh but what they're doing they don't
want to see you on one of those uh
Walmart videos where you're getting gang
tackled by a bunch of security guards I
got a rotisserie chicken in my hand some
old vets grabbing your cart I was a
black and white Kippy getting the [__]
kicked in
a rotisserie chicken on
that was from yesterday
coming out of Home Depot these are my
two by fours uh
well though also what they started doing
which I respect in the you know they
started uh posting pictures of people
who steal oh that's the worst but
they're like dude they're like [__]
computer print out like never home never
a good look jammed up which I respect
air out the dirty laundry keep these
neighborhoods clean you know what I mean
I can get the trash out of there it was
section for Cutters like you
well no and we'll say he only has two
items and then his wife will show up
with over there's an underst there's an
understanding right so okay so there uh
uh they're they're recently added the
the self-checkouts yes right within the
past year or so which if you get jammed
up over there you're really on your own
because the guy that works over there
but the reason he's over there is
because he doesn't want to deal with the
line so he doesn't want to have to come
over and help you but you always have to
have somebody come over and help you
because those things all mess up where's
all this AI what's going on I've never
had to have the guy oh you gotta scan it
again
that happens every time I go into CVS
yeah with you
you're a Jew you're the problem I see it
happen to other people
getting my core receding asking me for
my ID don't you worry corticine and
spray paint
I gotta say that kid at home he's got an
arts and crafts project here tomorrow
get off my back how did you mind your
business pal last time I checked this is
America I'm gonna buy whatever the hell
I want now where's that cold flu
medicine
but he got a case of Sudafed will you my
allergies are really acting up
I'm in there in the Walter White suit
[Laughter]
um so go ahead so it wasn't becoming of
me but there was a long line for what
the so this is what happens is there
still it's an older neighbor there's a
lot of older people in the neighborhood
still and they don't [__] with the
self-checkout now so they wait in line
and it's typically all one line right
like and then it splits
uh and there's T you know so the first
like six people in line are waiting or
whatever the first handful of people
online are waiting to go to the the OG
traditional register sure but now
there's a bunch of people behind them
just waiting to go to the self checkout
they don't have it broken up no because
it's tight it's so small gotcha and it's
sometimes it's like if you have a barber
that you like it's one line but some
people wait to go to the checkout and
then other people just go around yes all
right and a lot of times when you're up
there it's on the burden is on you when
you're up there to [__] scoot around
the blue hairs and go to the
self-checkout excuse me you guys waiting
for the are you guys waiting for the
regular checkout are you gonna go to
Snapchat okay yeah I'm over here or a
lot of times no go I'm not doing it over
there I don't know these computers a lot
of times the guy I forgot my pin I will
be like hey over here you know what I
mean like if next cell next up and
self-checkout yeah oh it's available and
they'll go no no go around well whatever
happened was jammed up you ever get hit
with credit card only oh all of ours are
credit card only thanks yeah it's like I
got a handful of nickels that's
when you find out who's cash forward
who's going into that guy bored up for a
minute I was like you're paying cash I'm
like no I am not yeah this is going on a
car Reddit card um
so there's a long line and I'm in the
back and I have a bit of a
body is a bowel issue happening okay and
it was one of those things now what's a
guy like you like to use
I already [__] myself this week get out
of my way are you uh are you a carry
cart guy or are you a push cart guy this
thank you for asking this is a very good
question this is the show we are not
changing
um uh my dad instilled in me that you
would be ladylike if you didn't if you
weren't able to carry all the groceries
on your own so we were a no-fly wait no
you're just walking around with yeah
wait a minute I got stuff under my
armpits dude wait hold on I swear to God
that's crazy it's I can't do it unless I
you can't use the little basket
unless I know that I really won't be
able to carry everything what are you a
divorce cop I'm like a cat what are you
getting what do you mean there's no way
you can shop for the week for you and
your wife we don't shop for the week a
couple days
what was I getting I'm sure there was a
frozen pizza I believe I was getting the
cauliflower I bet you were using it as a
shelf no I should have I had this guy's
the pepperoni pizza kid I had a I had a
cannon how many pepperoni pizzas do you
think he ate this weekend ah four or
five more I was the Indy 500. it was a
pepperoni 500.
man I love the pepperoni person you
bought them for me
no no no no I'm talking about if they're
at restaurants I didn't have multiple
pepperoni pizzas at restaurants you had
one at the airport on your way out of
town sure they said it was the special
um but you bought them for the house yes
so I mean like okay I like to live
vicariously through you I'm 28 beers
deep and there's a [__] self-rising
crust pepperoni DiGiorno in the freezer
I'm not gonna throw that in the oven
which like a jerk off uh sidebar real
quick
um our buddy Pat came with us was giving
me a lot of [__] about my uh frozen
pizza heating techniques I'm I'm a
frozen pizza guy right not after what I
saw here's the thing I'm checking the
plate I'm checking the tape here's the
thing so so the the the the the
discussion came down to I pulled out the
cookie sheet and I put tinfoil on it and
I went to throw the DiGiorno on there to
slide it in oh I didn't see any of this
yes and Pat freaked out
um well because it was two pizzas that
were half hanging off the bed
that was a holding pattern no stop
listen let me myself that was a holding
pattern after Pat said no just put it on
the grate so I just put them there I was
I had folded up a piece of tin foil into
like four so it had a little girth to it
and I was gonna put the cauliflower one
on there and put it in
but he said and you guys are staunch uh
it's on the box go right on the great
it's on the bar I'm not allowed to do
that at my house
says who your mommy
yeah you're nuts I can't I'm not allowed
because the cheese drips onto the bottom
of the oven again because you're not
doing it right probably go back to the
self-checkout at CVS you're jamming
everybody up every which way should I
let me put on a great tote [__] Henry
jam up over here and I can't just put it
in the cookie sheet because then I gotta
scrub the cookie sheet so I put a piece
of tin foil down and I throw it out
you're like the little kid who sleeps
over and is like at my house we're not
allowed to have marshmallow cereal yeah
my mom says I can't touch the toaster
then the parents aren't wondering why
yeah
it interferes with my medicine
and I lose it
I had a friend we were down come
upstairs I'm wearing the dead suits
walking around
good day sir playing business man now
I'm the daddy uh I had a friend who just
we were dude 16 maybe I think I driven
down the shore and we woke up in the
morning we're gonna they had like Bagels
out to make you know I was gonna like oh
I was like you know we all like get up
we'll start making Bagels like all right
we'll cut we're gonna cut the bagels we
don't need to be making any trips to the
hospital I was like buddy I've been
smoking cigs out front all morning I
need a sesame bagel with cream cheese
stuff you feel like I can scoop and
toast with my own everything what do you
not have been working I've been on jobs
on seven eight what are we doing I'm a
latchkey kid what are you talking about
I haven't seen my parents in weeks I
know I was like dude okay man it's
[__] wrapping this up real quick
let's get the [__] out of here go get
some tally nuts
you were uh beating up old men in the no
so what happened it was it was an act of
frustration and I I got the sweat bead
boy like growing on the Brad it's time
is of the essence you know what I mean
how many things do you have I have a uh
and you're carrying it all I thought for
sure this conversation was either going
to be I'm a basket guy or I'm a cart guy
and the one thing I will say about the
city is that they have these little Mini
Cooper carts oh man no the Little John's
because when you're down when you're
down in The Burbs you take a cart you
get you get one of those big ones and
you [__] you use the lane it's an ego
thing I can't do it man unless I'm like
loaded up for a barbecue or something a
nice quiet ice cold grocery store in the
summer around nine o'clock with a big I
don't care juggle to Crate of oranges
one of those pizza hot dogs no I don't
care if I'm getting a pack of gum I get
the cart yeah I don't know we're not uh
really I'm not my obviously my mom yeah
of course uh yeah I'm just not a cart
guy never have been and at this point I
don't think or a basket I like I said
I'll do a basket if I know I if I if
I've already failed with like the stuff
I'm going to get I'm like adds up so
quick and then you grab a couple extra
things I mean you look like a real loser
walking around the grocery store this
feels like if you if you went back and
you would really you're like why are we
doing this and your dad would just be
like honestly we're just trying to save
money
sure that's a total only be it I don't
know it was more of like yeah we're not
doing that and I was like all right so
the scene is set I have a cauliflower
pizza in my one hand I have a can of
diet Dr Pepper in my other hand and I
swear to God I have another can of diet
Dr Pepper under my armpit who buys
singles at the ground that's why that's
all they sell
yeah it's not like a it's not a grocery
store yeah it's a market we've gone over
there single cans they have them like
call not buying them warm they have them
in like the front like okay individual
checkouts all right and I would be
buying a bottle but they don't sell the
bottles only can so now I gotta buy two
because Kippy needs more than 12 ounces
sure what are we doing around here yeah
soda can should be pounders
whoa right I mean there's got to be
legislation against that
individual Pounders because once you
crack that you got to finish
yeah there's got to be legislation
because around there that's where we're
drawing the line that do people on Dr
Pepper Pounders that's what that's why
we're putting the brakes on it people
would be losing feet left and right if
that was the case this is crazy whole
place is falling no but that doesn't
make any sense because they sell three
liters two liters you can put a cap on
that that's for like family consumption
a can you have to say
I'm assuming because don't they have all
the soda taxes and what about beers
beers coming Pounders that's got alcohol
in it this is America
remember we saw those Mega Pounders at
uh at the Indy 500 the 20 I think there
were 22s or something they were monsters
like a football
yeah they were all right pretty cool
um Indy 500 knows their way around a
Bloody Mary I'll tell you that oh made
them fresh
oh I was putting those things away yeah
you same town was shocked at the
veracity uh you drank those things oh I
gotta get across the river
so whatever I did say we're dragging
this out but I uh I knew people in front
of me were waiting to use the
self-checkout line okay right and I just
saw that it wasn't happening like
because that now nobody made a move no
well it's also too tight people have the
car it's the whole nine yards see with
the car you're not agile you're in line
you're in line you can't bust a U-turn
in line when you got a cart so that's
why I'm freewheeling over here you gotta
be able to stick him how did you do the
frustrated walkover in case anybody said
anything no you tend to be frustrated
now just you're a cutter now what I'm
partnered with a cutter I was gonna ship
myself that was the main thing so I just
[__] I sold it because I'm anti-cutter
there was and you can ask new guy Luke
because when we when we're over at Home
Depot that one time I put the kaibosh on
a lady trying to cut in front oh I'm a
big no cutter of course I wait my turn I
pay my taxes
but I'm going to also ship myself and
these people aren't making moves this is
New York City kill or be killed what are
we doing so I just [__] see that give
you a New York minute so I see no one's
making a move there's two open
self-checkout writers the guy's like
hello hello hello so I'm like uh well
what are we just all gonna wait till
these old birds in that case so I just
bust a U-turn [__] flank them up the
other aisles got it I was in and out you
were kind of leading people yeah it was
more like I we got to break the ice here
somehow because I had to pull the plug I
had a guy try to cut in line uh at the
at the race in the the morning of the
race we were we were waiting in line to
get uh some some some liquor drinks and
uh there was a nice line formed and this
goon came over on the side with his uh
with his hillbilly girlfriend and like
really tried to like just kind of creep
over and get in the line now yeah wow
yeah you gotta know what that dude if
I'm in line for beer and someone's
cutting you that's I was like Horton in
the paint no that's like the Pearly
gauge you can't cut the line there you
know what I mean that's that's sacred
grounds sacred yeah but all in all I
felt bad about it but hey you gotta do
you gotta do it you know what I mean I
typically would have waited if I if
there wasn't pressing issues yeah what
about you you cut in front of people at
the grocery store never on purpose like
like premeditated but in a situation
like that when opportunity to ask the
person in front of you excuse me no but
that's like when you're like late for a
flight excuse me are you waiting I'd
have to ask 10 people and by that point
they would have [__] you know hey you
snooze you lose
or I could have just I kind of was
operating in a sense I guess none of
them are using the self-checkout and I
[__]
because this guy here we get you to
sleep at night pepperoni boy
Dirtbag you got a real beef with me and
my pepperonis because you keep bringing
it up yeah yeah you got a real problem I
love it and hate it all at the same time
I wish I could go back and do more
flatbreads and more personal pizzas hey
if history's shown anything you got a
future in them okay
don't don't act like you're [__] Iron
Man over here ah yeah you know my eating
days are behind me I saw you drink 80
beers on Saturday fair enough okay let's
talk about Factor back to factor factor
Summer's here you don't want to spend
hours in the kitchen cooking slaving
over a hot stove you want to try to keep
it tight we're trying to tighten it up a
little bit you know it's a great
solution
Factor pre-made meals you throw them in
the microwave two minutes you can eat
right off the tray it's fantastic or if
you want to class it up a little bit
Kippy throws them into Skelly hello it's
fantastic you feel like a little chef
and you don't have to do much two three
minutes in a skillet the food's good
it's great uh they have over 34 Chef
created dietitian approved options every
week and there's always something new to
try if you're looking for a calorie
conscious options calorie smart meals
coming around 550 550 calories or if you
need an extra boost of protein check out
factors Protein Plus meals with 30 grams
of protein per serving there you go it
keeps you just you can order a couple a
week it keeps it tight so you just have
a better option you know what I mean
instead of going like I'm gonna go grab
pizza you're like I gotta factor in the
fridge I'll be in do three minutes boom
uh if you're vegan vegetarian keto
there's something delicious that waits
for you too head to factorymeals.com
garbage50 and use code garbage 50 to get
50 off your first box they're giving a
form away fifty percent that's code
garbage 50 at factormeels.com garbage50
to get 50 off your your first box do it
the link is in the description okay
let's talk about Chief oh baby let's
talk about an OG from day one getting
behind the first sponsor ever we got on
our own yeah gang do yourself a favor go
over to sheath pick yourself up some
sheath underwear because you know what
stinks having your balls stick to your
thigh in the middle of the summer when
it's cooking outside they got the pocket
you throw the nuts in there yeah it's
got two pouches one for your deck one
for the ball bag to keep everything
Breezy I put it all in one
got it all hanging out the front uh
she's underwear comes in tons of cool
patterns and help you look good and feel
comfortable they are the best underwear
I've ever used they are fan freaking
tastic I'm telling you gang I can't
endorse them enough they're awesome I
call my sexy underwear I put them on and
take a shot at the wife go to
sheathunderwear.com and use code garbage
and get 20 off your first order baby
plus sheets underwear is 100 money back
guarantee there you go that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code garbage
get sheath under underwear support the
show support your balls I'm telling you
gang it's the best stuff I got in my
life
do it uh Gang This is a family episode
as you know when you sign up for the old
patreon over there we will answer your
garbage question on here just the best
way to do it uh the homies get first
crack at it we love you and I gotta be
honest it's a [__] party over there
it's not Lions he is a cutter but it's a
there's a lot of [__] going on over
there it's a fun time I just saw there's
like over 120 episodes if you sign up
today is over 120 episodes of [__]
bonus aygs over 120 episodes of hard
feelings plus you get all the bonus
videos the [__] all the [__] we do
we're cranking out tour Vlogs the whole
nine yards I had new guy Luke and Tebow
were really working this week oh man
they were new guy Luke had crazy full
access yeah people just because he had
that big ass camera yeah they were just
like oh this is a camera guy we should
get him one of those Canon pennies
that's what I said yeah stealing my idea
get a 5xl in that yeah
uh but all right let's get into a gang
this is from Eric B have you ever jet
skied in shoes and socks that's crazy
yeah that's I feel like you're running
from somebody there that's like a bank
job or something I thought it's
guaranteed that you're gonna fall in on
a jet I've only been on a jet ski once
in my life and we got arrested well I
know what we're doing down in Wildwood
I'll do that on a jet ski would I fit am
I allowed
I've always riding around on a jet ski
limo
he dudes that's like a bigger jet ski no
it depends on the craft depends on the
craft the watercraft yeah gotcha 350 to
600 depending
get you and new guy Luke on here that
[__] fishtail I'm holding on tight I
mean if DJ Khaled can whip around Miami
on his there you go yes I would 100 God
do that okay yeah okay this is shaping
not shoes and socks though because
you're going in right uh I don't always
necessarily think you do yeah I mean
that's crazy to me I guess in my head
you're using that as like Transportation
it's like going to work or something
which if you lived on like a big lake or
and you had to zip across to get you're
working in some Maritime type deal not
about working in an aqua style
environment there were kids growing up
on the lake we lived on that did that
before they had licenses would ride jet
skis to the homie scripts yeah where's
this down St Pete's not Lake Norman
North Carolina okay why don't you live
there
a couple years
okay I know we knew he was from North
Carolina I knew he was in North Carolina
but I never knew anything about a lake
oh yeah a few years Lake people
wait like all the time Lake people
except we were the family that are I
think we need a price we got to find out
what the real deal is here you've been
real Shifty with a lot of this stuff no
I just tell you and you forget because
you never told us
oh Jason from a lake yeah the Lakewood
they didn't even they didn't have a
lakefront property they had like we
lived we lived across the street from
the lakefronts my mom gave up on the
roof together if the Johnsons had their
windows open you could see as far as the
eye could see yeah my fall when the
leaves are gone my mom gave my brother
water skis for Christmas and we did not
own a boat oh yeah that's right I
remember that go make friends yeah
go find some rich people that's like
that's like gonna get a basketball and
no net yeah would that work on your
handles would it freeze in the winter so
you can walk on it no that didn't get
that cold huh all right I guess that
checks out uh but yeah let's get you on
a jet ski sure I actually just had a
phone call with the guy for about a
about a house jet ski guy no yeah you
get jet skis left and right down there
okay that was a real shyster sounded
like a real perk at if we're being
honest sounded like he was nodding off
on the other end that's good we got a
good deal nah he was really he was
playing Hardball about the ages of
people I said I got a cousin new guy
Luke who's 25. maybe he just comes for a
day or two go buddy I'm out what yeah I
go we got one guy he's 50.
and she's like yeah yeah I was like
everybody's 30 in their 30s and 40s and
he's like I was like I got one guy who's
25 and he's like I don't know about him
I'm like well buddy Jesus for that
reason he's a little Hellraiser yeah
um but no never skied or never no
obviously jet ski in my shoes maybe like
if I had like Lake shoes on if we were
like swimming in the lake and you had
shoes listen if I was down there and
like you're saying if it was a thing
dude that would be my primary mode of
transportation if I lived in some kind
of Harbor or something like that I'd be
zipping around that thing all the time
oh yeah if I like worked on below deck
take the skiff out
crushing season four right now we're
sailing yet I don't like the sailing no
get out of here my Captain's all right
captain captain captain Glenn shout out
to him yeah did you see that Gary run a
tight ship do you see that uh the cruise
that's in high seas right now
no what happened oh there's [__]
jammed up out there where they were like
off Bahamas or something yeah they were
real like the [__] 90 mile an hour
winds were blowing the patio doors open
to the room and stuff they couldn't keep
them closed yikes yeah
I'm [__] kind of nervous dude I can't
wait uh all right fully loaded Cruz yeah
if you're going hit us up baby yeah 100
uh all right this one's from Patrick ten
ten dollar guy here that just made that
up ten dollar guy here never had one
dollar dude uh what's up I'm a ten
dollar dude are you garbage if your dad
said his car has 450 AC four windows
down and 50 miles an hour
so no AC right but he just puts all four
windows down and does 50. that was kind
of our dude I honestly don't remember
having like good working air
conditioning
I don't think that hit until
where it was like a midnight where it
was great I think that was like I'll say
early 90s yeah I mean I I can't recall
Mike had a couple of uh company cars
that were like cutlasses yeah but those
are [__] those are brand new cars
nobody was driving around in brand new
cars back then yeah every used car
market was [__] you were in some big
hunky [__] you got from Nana or whatever
when the AC didn't work shout out to the
Ford Matador uh that had that new AC
yeah leather seats that would [__]
burn your thighs yeah that'll cook an
egg in there yeah we my first car was a
dead B in the back oh man I remember
that my mom my mom's phone
yikes it was like a [__] burial
ground for honeybees or whatever it was
they were [__] jammed up back there
oh my my grandfather's Buick you'd get
in and the seat belt would be so hot it
would like brand new oh yeah dude dude
your young tender skin oh dude like
you're cauterizing a bullet hole oh man
things sucked
um
what was I going to say God damn it uh
uh AC the AC but even I mean I was in oh
I got my first car in 2003 probably
shout out to a 1995 Chevy Lumina 2009 to
1996 Chevy Lumina and the AC went on
that quick
and like everybody kept going you have
to like charge it I guess you were like
out of the fridge yeah but I guess there
was a leak or something because like
and they would charge it and would be
off for I was a big Windows whatever the
thing when you moved it across the from
hot to call the lever that was bad news
yeah yeah
but now I say it all the time I'm a huge
AC on and windows down I know the Uber's
guide the Uber drivers get mad which I
we said
shut up nobody wait dick move for me or
him for you what because you're not
getting the a the air conditioner will
cool the car better than the window
but you get fresh air plus you get in
there sometimes and the the air
freshener it's like burning your
eyeballs I know but that's not
everything dude every time you get in
the car they go you roll you're like hey
can I get some AC and then you
immediately put the window down he's
like did you want AC did you not want AC
it's it's an odd move I'm lighting up a
heater yeah I got smoke in here
uh yeah all right I'm a dick I mean not
a dick but it is I'm just saying it's
nobody ever gets into an Uber and says
hey hit the AC I want to put the windows
down like when you get in anybody's car
hey turn the window turn put the windows
up and put in the AC there's nothing
more luxurious than having oh yeah
that's America the AC on and the windows
down man that's a good yeah some Steely
Dan playing or something
that's all right cracking a little
Deacon Blues you know what I mean
I don't know where I pulled that one
from
it's all right
um all right let's see this Carolina
guys oh yeah Steely Dan go on and raise
up didn't they take their shirt off and
spin around their head like a helicopter
oh yeah yeah
uh all right this one some of your hmm
is it garbage to order a whole sheet
cake eat half then [__] full full
refund claiming it didn't taste like I
thought it would P.S this works at
Publix info gathered for my sweet aunt
Linda now that's [__] up
I get
yeah I mean
I'm assuming you're jammed up sure
and you need some sort of
food although I'll say this I that is a
dick move they're trash there is
especially if it's his aunt
these broads
that run households that are on budgets
that were maybe on budgets when the kids
were growing up and now whatever they
fall into they have a world that we're
not really privy to
they play by different I know Patty
they play by different rules at the
grocery store
that's all part of the game oh yeah
cutting it taking half back I'll return
this I'll get this I'll do that give me
two for one on this they're cutting the
rain checks rain checks were big they
know the whole system yeah and and the
people that work there it's all part of
the game they don't they're they're into
it they're cool yeah they also don't I
mean like I worked at a grocery store
and customer service for a long time
those big companies don't give a [__]
they go like all right yeah just give
them
they're like hey I wanted to buy 400
cans of kidney beans and like well we're
out of them they're like well they're
they're a nickel this week and they go
yeah come back next week we'll give them
all day we don't care yeah they're
moving units I see what you're saying
and a half a sheet cake can really go
far
sure I assume This Woman's trying you
know between heroin of Doses and [__]
needs to keep her sugar levels up that's
what I'm picking up a Publix in Florida
Aunt Linda bringing back half a Cookie
Monster
my mom each one says happy birthday
Linda my mom pulled a move recently my
dad got food poison we went out to eat
and my mom was like we should call them
and ask them to refund some of the bills
whoa
shrimp yeah you're on your own it's
right there on the goddamn menu there's
a little star consuming raw seafood
could Jam you up it was at a Denny's
what did Burger King say
did she get the money back she didn't
ask okay but I do get the idea of like
are your you know your husband you know
because someone else paid
I should call and see if I can get a
gift card back
yeah now you're rolling the dice with
that stuff squidding pasta in North
Carolina what do you want it was in New
York City it was an Irish restaurant oh
you're nuts
side
[Laughter]
I used to be a tenement
going in there and ordering [__] uni
Oysters Rockefeller on a Sunday
apparently the sushi got him sick at
Tammany Hall I never understood why
squidding pasta oh yeah man you're
really rolling the dice with that let me
tell you it's delicious I've been jammed
up on that a couple of times that ink
don't last
that ain't Sharpie I can tell you that
that turns plus the toner tastes
terrible
uh yeah that's man I didn't think of it
how jammed up was that the professor oh
Dr D all the way really oh yeah yeah man
food poisoning are really
really hit me up yeah that's that ain't
great I wouldn't recommend doing that
that's that's a tough one uh but I do
kind of get it at the same time it's
different rules man sure it's different
rules but yeah those those birds in the
supermarket they play for keeps it's
like jailhouse rules they don't care
Booter scamming who's getting cut they
don't matter and they know each other
in in in in in in The Burbs there's a
good chance that one of the ladies over
in that bakery at the grocery store or
behind the deli is you know Mary Pat so
and so who went to school with this one
or you remember they used to be married
to David
yeah we got that down there
every time I go in there I gotta get a
song and dance about what Billy's doing
and Tommy's doing and this and that and
the other thing and how's your mom and
papa yeah it's a whole thing
it's gonna be my lunch meat lady
Slice It Anyway
jamming me up uh all right let's see
here this is
um
this one's from Jake upberg ten dollar
Bozo here's a garbage if the only family
portrait you have was taken at an old
west portrait studio at an amusement
park
it's all right
those things are so trashy I know and
I'm pretty sure my cousin proposed to
his wife in one really drop down on a
knee I think so but if anybody you can't
get dirt on that that's a rental he's
got a Tommy gun and a ring
hahaha
now marry me or else what do you say we
uh make this official sweetheart
yeah they're big on the boardwalk I
always all those Booth photo type shits
big on them gotta do that down the shore
what one of those photo things okay yeah
we for sure the squad's gonna do that a
bunch of gangsters I don't know if they
have 5x I'll bring my own suits on hand
fat guy Ryan you guys are all dressed up
like Mobsters I'm in a cowboy you got
you got your bathing suit on
I always wanted those you gotta saddle
for the fat one
Luke's sitting on me
who you could spray him gray make him an
elephant make this a safari one I
remember I had one of those done with uh
with an old girlfriend and and her
family when we were down there uh on
vacation uh down down at the shore and I
remember I was probably 20 at the time
and I we had never you know my dad was
never swinging for that and I was like
man if I could just get one of those I'm
gonna look like the coolest guy like
when they take my picture and I'm gonna
make it look real other people all look
like idiots but when I get back
delusions of grandeur started at a young
age I'll put the face on I'll look cool
it'll look like a newspaper it'll look
like a newspaper and I remember I got it
done and I was just like
I look like the biggest dork no way
really yeah it sucked uh but those
things are awesome I've I've speaking of
Pat I've mentioned this before but we
did we we did a music video on the
boardwalk he told us to the Men in Black
theme song and the only the height of
technological Advance at that point was
just like us in front of dinosaurs
and I was trying to stick to dance so it
was a tough one dude it was at like 17th
in the boardwalk I was going all singing
into a stromboli oh dude we had like
those like big microphones I had
sunglasses on a top hat the family
portrait
as noted behind me
is a real
man it's never it never went smoothly we
never I don't think we've ever done one
of those that's our only one right there
we would do like and I remember that
specific night of what a nightmare was
we literally as soon as they snapped
that was we smiled and then it was just
chaos before and after I had a huge cut
under my eye that my mom put makeup on
because my brother elbowed me or
something like that I was crying I was
screaming it was like a Wednesday now we
did like a Wednesday at eight
Wednesday nights yeah we went to like
some studio it wasn't Olin Mills I think
we did one at Olin Mills at Sears when I
was younger with me and my brother I was
like leaning on like a like a tree trunk
or something like that photographers
like all right everybody in you're in
the corner like you gotta cut me
back
Patty was screaming it was a nightmare
yeah I don't why don't that stuff to I
think I thought at least the way I
viewed our families like it was like why
would you waste the money doing that
just get the picture at the [__]
barbecue like that's what we would
always get one at Christmas yeah
probably Easter and that was it school
pictures but never go into a place also
it was a broken family it'd be weird
just my mom and the kids we would have
to do a thing
they're all just individual photos
oh mug shots
this is now a silhouette of a man your
face here
um
we would do that at holidays too we
would do like one with just a foleys one
with just the the McMahon's
one with just to this sure now all the
grandkids together yeah yeah all that
stuff which viewers always on the
fringes
because they weren't technically my side
of this enemy wasn't technically my my
Aunt Mary who was like The Matriarch on
my mom's side of the family wasn't
technically my grandmother but she
basically was my grandma gotcha you know
uh still made good with the Christmas
presents I'll tell you yeah she better
shout out to Mary Ryan Camp let's talk
about fumes oh baby fumes back oh
however bad habits maybe you never fold
your laundry maybe you've been known to
be a little outspoken at family
gathering shut up when you got two Tree
in you uh-huh a couple little loudmouth
soups fume is the Innovative device that
replaces that nasty hand-to-mouth habit
you want to do less yes which you do it
lets you remove the bad while still
keeping the Habit making it much easier
uh transition for your brain and your
body there's no electronics fumes
completely natural there's no Vapor
harmful chemicals fume just uses air and
all natural delicious flavors like white
cranberry and crisp mint shout out to
the crane crazy peasy they taste great
uh they send them to us it's fantastic
when you're you know it's a better habit
if you catch my drift stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy
enjoyable and even fun few has served
over 100 000 customers and has thousands
of success stories and there's no reason
you that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanities break up from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to head to
trifum.com use code garbage to save 10
off when you get the journey packed
today that's try fume
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code garbage to
save an additional 10 off your first
order do it baby
um all right this one's from patio
furniture first time long time which I'm
pretty sure is a lie I know that name
ever had a cinder block inside your
house
that's all right [__] yeah dude and I
gotta so we have them now
you do because you have the you have
that I know I know the cinder block and
board dining room set
the tree from the tree fort collection
man those things are a ton I know I know
listen in your 20s with your boys you
gotta spray paint them then you got
something to know naked cinder blocks
unfinished you got to put some kind of
glaze on it what are you nuts
I you just have cinder blocks in your
home right now I walk into your house
there's a cinder block there there's
about eight of them
not eight I don't know I mean I should
be running this operation this is crazy
they're small it's my wife it's low
price the Europeans man I have cinder
blocks over there what are you talking
about what are you talking about cinder
block technology in in Germany they
don't have cinder blocks in Europe
why not why would they what I don't even
know what that means isn't that an
American thing
I'm sure they have bricks that are
cinder blocks do they I I don't I mean
that's that might make sense but that's
I'm so stupid I don't think I've ever
thought of that no their buildings are
built with cinder blocks yeah they had
them 30 years before us really yeah
before the [__] you find that out
cinderblock.net that's all lies that's
all call me propaganda that's just big
concrete
bricks in your house is tough
yeah a tire in your house is tough there
should be no reason A tire's in your
house I had we had one in the foyer for
a while I don't know why
what yeah there was one on the back
porch I can't remember what it was I
think somebody had gotten new tires and
my mom wanted to save them
make mulch out of them or something I
got the dog chew on it yeah between
fights yeah because for a while
it was stylish to have a inverted Tire
in the front yard as like a Potter yes
and you would slice the top of it sure
so it fanned out I mean I don't know if
that was ever in
that wasn't in the early 80s that was
that was in style that was a thing with
dirt bags sure yeah it was yeah I'll
give you that she would she painted they
were painted white uh-huh well you know
we also had for some reason in our
backyard because I kept a frog in there
for a little while we had huge pieces of
the ceramic pipe
like like
sewer Main Line okay
it was like the size of a trash of like
an outside trash can okay and it had
that lip on it where it connected to the
other thing I don't like soil pipe nah
nah I think it was a sewer pipe yes yeah
they call it soil pipes cast iron it was
huge cast iron yeah I don't know why we
had one of those we had one in our
backyard probably scrapping I think they
did I think we stole they stole it from
the construction that was still going on
in the neighborhood if I remember
correct [__] thieves
yeah we had uh we had tulips and we had
like a little American flag in that
thing I remember when I figured out it
was a tire I was like what the [__] who
didn't remember that who did this I
remember that at all yeah they were like
yeah they flipped in turn into planners
on like the front porch or whatever yeah
oh yikes
real trashy welcome to the Foley's home
and junkyard everybody yeah uh all right
this one's from Alexandria are you
garbage if you take your baby to
PetSmart to look at the animals instead
of going to a zoo
[Laughter]
we used to go heavy to look at the pets
back in the day when they really when
they when you go into like a mom-and-pop
pet store and they would have everything
from [__] fish and birds and
everything the whole nine yards yeah
even uh there was one in the mall in the
Neshaminy Mall we would go to
I was right in the Corpus it was called
Critters and we would go and if we were
lucky enough
a pet store named green yeah let's go
look at the roaches
it was mostly moles
Critters
um welcome to PES
welcome to varmints
you kill it you eat it
um can we get a silver fish
a little scumbag I'll take three minutes
give me three minnows and a bag of
mosquitoes will you
Critters that is garbage pretty sure it
was Critters and then I think that there
was some sort of if I remember correctly
there was some sort of Legal Financial
debacle that happened it came back as
Critters too like they had to change the
name legally so it wasn't Critters man
um but we could smell that place that
though yeah the the wood chips yeah you
would always have to go we will if we
were in the mall we had to go to
Critters and look if we had to yeah and
every now and then the fish tanks they
had a nice fish tank set up that was
real relaxing I would love to get a fish
tank love it I think the smell ain't
great though no you gotta really stay on
it because I'm not a guy who stays on
stuff they skeetheart out I can't do
them fish yeah don't like fish tanks I
would love to have a fish tank in my
room and go to bed at night I don't know
if I'd want one in the room I love that
it's like sleeping at Critters
uh hey that's not a bad idea what
couldn't do it now but if you were a pet
store and have sleepovers
the parents would stay but how cool if
you were a nine-year-old kid having a
sleepover at a pet shop you're doing a
lock-in at Critters yeah that's not that
cool
also what kind of what is wrong with you
if you're a parent gonna sleep at
Critters no
uh-uh no way your Dad's sleeping in the
massage chair up front but every now and
then they would let us he would let my
dad would let us take one out and like
you know you'd go play in the room with
one what would a puppy oh wow oh man and
I think a team guy that's like playing
with fire with three kids who will start
crying sure [__] tell your mom to
take them back to court or whatever man
we were like
real like there was one thing I'm like
can we keep him and he's like no and I'm
like oh this why do we [__] tease
ourselves yeah that's crazy uh-huh blue
balled myself yeah you never do that but
it was a good thing you never get close
to a puppy dog if you're not taking it
home I know [__] really Jimmy
thinking about him for the rest of your
life uh but I guess as a kid we were an
SPCA family
uh I don't know where my dad got Patches
but we got Rusty we only dealt in
ex-cons it was like a halfway house
everybody came from the SPCA I remember
going and going in there as a kid
was weird you go within it there's a lot
of pressure on a little kid you got
[__] 30. it's not like customer
especially back in the day it was like
you walked into like a Cell Block
literally it wasn't like the pain a
bunch of guys on [__] death row
you're in there walking The Green Mile
look into who you're gonna [__] say I
know I felt so bad oh my God I didn't do
it man they gave me a public lawyer
something's egregious
yeah it'll Jam yeah they were I remember
walking in to get ready and you would
see some you're like nobody's getting
him no he's done he's eating an intern
buddy oh they have ones where they have
like signs on like not friendly oh we'll
take him yeah not good with kids you're
like what the [__] it's [__] in there
like Lecter get out of here it's less of
an adoption more of a stay of execution
yeah
the governor
mac and cheese and some
some rotisserie chicken this is last
meal that was a [__] brutal brutal
yeah wow that stuck with me I remember
go walk in that that faint smell of dog
[__] and like cleaning cleaning solution
that's just a long stretch I'm sure we
yanked Tyler out of
then they sent him back for a couple of
days because he was being a psycho
sounds like you got a guy yeah but my
dad couldn't do it so that's up these
are my kids and that's Tyler that's when
we that's when we branded ourselves the
foleys as we never we never returned
pets because he did it for like a night
or two and he's like [__] I gotta go oh
yeah I gotta go back and get this dog
because he was a two-time loser at that
point what do you think right in with
the family
you send them back
I put them down there with with the
sisters in the basement
that's how they got Andy Dufresne no
thanks catch him in the laundry room uh
all right let's see here uh this is from
Adriana ten dollar homie never had a
question read but is it garbage if your
parents buy meat like a drug deal
growing up my dad would send my mom to
weird location slash parking lots to
pick up meat from a guy in an Escalade
dude if you're meat guy's driving in an
escrow I'll Trust a guy in a white van
because that's what meat gets carted
around in meat don't belong in an
Escalade you he was she was buying Coke
that's [__] Bam Bam she just put the
air up real high yeah maybe in a cooler
in a van we used to get the guys that
sell [__] in a van
a lot the speaker guys would draw yo you
need speakers ah [__] I forgot about
those speaker guys yeah the speaker Guys
these were all stolen right I us or
broken or fake or something there used
to be a lot more they weren't Best Buy
Vans there used to be a lot more guys
cruising around a Suburban neighborhood
it still might be we're just not in
there selling [__] yeah
now it's solar this [__] take a walk
we used to get the guys make with the
T-Bones from North Carolina we always
over North Carolina or South Carolina
all the furniture and carpet guys would
come up
in [__] 18 wheelers and drive down
the street park up and just go knock on
all the doors go and look come this is
all the [__] we have come take a look at
it and they were all they were always
from North Carolina and South Carolina a
lot of manufacturing down here yeah get
a loveseat or something oh everybody
come out hopping on the truck sure I'm
doing this trying to get a couple of
hungs out of it yeah I remember I
remember I visually can remember Patty
walking on the back of a tractor trailer
looking at furniture
we're like what the [__] like an FBI
agent open it up
you got paperwork for these love seats
off the grounds between her fingers hey
the puncture looking for he's got a
switchblade
cutting it open
that's North Carolina
all right give me two low seats
wrap this up
yeah man I remember that [__] though Big
Air in the summer they would come in and
man you would see them we'd be on our
bikes like in the neighborhood somewhere
else you'd see him a couple blocks away
we would we would ride home like we were
[__] Paul Revere
the semis are coming the semis are
coming we okay then we've been
we've been screaming down the [__]
down the hill letting everybody know
you're about to get some cheap [__]
really seriously we've been watching
growing pains on a brand new love seat
in a couple hours
yeah that was big man it was real big
that and we had a uh we had like a candy
Bakery guy
who used to roll around and the one
neighborhood we lived in Wilkes-Barre it
was only me and my brother it was
looking back on it was a little suspect
but he really had the goods like there
was a okay it was like you know like a
bread truck not a not a uh not a Brink
straw yeah we're not from the town yeah
like a regular unmarked bread you
thought that you were gonna say bread
truck and I really thought you meant
sure about that life what are you
talking about
yeah okay oh yeah I forgot yeah yeah put
this whole town in my review
used to roll used to show up
right next door to our house every
Saturday he would be out there and he
seemed like a good guy he wasn't but I
could have been I could I honestly I
could have blocked some stuff out sure
but he had he had like great candy like
he had like the good fun dip he had the
good Blow Pops all the like the
strawberries and the grapes and the
Watermelons and all this stuff and then
he had fresh bread in there too now I
think he was on the level I had a bread
there you go he's luring kids into his
van with candy but he has bread so he's
on the level getting the fat kids trying
to get you in there
everybody I don't have a sweet tooth you
got any amorosos in there
he SWOT away the Skittles what's up with
the Focaccia we gotta wrap it up gang
gang we love you to death and we'll see
you next week peace